I told you last week that the Senate Intelligence
Committee had subpoenaed Donald Trump jr to
go and talk to them. And uh, the reason why
as far as we know is that because no matter
how many times Donald Trump likes to say at
the investigations aren't over and later in
the show, I'll give you a list of the open
investigations. I also told you that the fact
that there's a subpoena at all likely means
that the Senate Intelligence Committee already
requested that Don Jr appear and that he ignored
those requests causing the need for a subpoena.
And indeed Republicans on the Senate Intel
Committee are telling us that that's the case.
Now, why would the Senate intelligence committee
even want to talk to Don Jr? Because it appears
as though he lied to them through his teeth
and Republicans and Democrats don't like being
lied to. The Republicans and Democrats will
become instantly bipartisan when they feel
like their authority is not being respected
and they're not being taken.
Don Junior said that he knew nothing about
the Moscow Trump tower part project that he
had nothing to do with it. He wasn't talking
to anyone about it and yet Michael Cohen,
Trump's personal attorney later revealed under
oath that he briefed both don junior and Ivanka
Trump about that project about 10 times. What
else did don jr lie about during the Senate?
Intel? A testimony that he gave, I don't know,
but that's exactly what the Senate intelligence
committee now wants to find out. However,
there is at least one sitting senator Lindsey
Graham who is a known Trump brown nosing sycophant
whose urging don jr to just ignore the legal
subpoena from the same Senate on which Lindsey
Graham sits. This is against the law. Lindsey
Graham is suggesting that don jr break the
law so that he doesn't have to speak to his
colleagues in the Senate. Check this clip
out from Fox News on Sunday. So it was all
a set up. I think it will no mower. And what?
No more here soon.
W W was it also a setup to set up Donald Trump
jr? I mean, what is this subpoena of Donald
Trump junior coming out of your colleagues
and the Senate Intel Committee?
As I understand it, this subpoena that relates
to what Michael Cohen said about some meetings
and about the, uh, the Trump tower in Russia.
All I can say is that Richard Burrs, a very
good friend, he's trying hard to be bipartisan,
but anything based on what Michael Cohen said
is worthless testimony. Michael Cohen is a
worthless witness. And if I were Donald Trump
junior lawyer, I would tell him, you don't
need to go back into this environment anymore.
You've been there for hours and hours and
hours and nothing being alleged here changes
the outcome of the Mueller investigation.
I would call it a day. So first of all, if
Lindsey believes that Michael Cohen lied under
oath when he testified than Coen should be
punished for that. Now, do you think that
after everything and every one that's gone
down for lying to investigators and lying
to Congress, don't you think that if Michael
Cohen did lie to Congress about Don Juniors
involvement, that they would be charging Cohen
and potentially extending his prison sentence?
I mean, it's all completely ridiculous at
face value, but you might imagine, oh, Lindsey
Graham is going to get crushed for this, right?
I mean for a sitting senator to get away with
suggesting that legal subpoenas from his own
Senate be ignored. He's going to get crushed
by that, right? No, he's not. And the reason
why, uh, is that the same Republicans who
want to shut down government departments,
the same Republicans who say that they are
about small government, if you believe that
almost any government action is an overreach,
then you like the idea of taking power away
from the government and from the Senate. Lindsey
Graham, as crazy as what he's suggesting,
Ron Don Jr do is just break the law. Right?
Ignore the subpoena. Lindsey Graham is going
to be praised for his suggestion because so-called
small government conservatives and Trumpists
don't see this as Lindsey suggesting don jr
break the law.
They see this as Lindsey Graham doing the
small government conservative thing of limiting
the power of the Senate by suggesting people
ignore subpoenas, which of course they say
are bogus witch hunt subpoenas. And this sort
of comes down to a fundamental philosophical
difference that makes it safe for Lindsey
Graham to suggest on junior break the law.
And unfortunately this is how a government
becomes an oligarchy. This is how a government
moved towards autocracy. And this is the theme
of the Trump administration. The Senate has
subpoena powers, senators choosing to question
their own subpoena power over the family of
the president of the United States is another
way to usher in or to allow or to look the
other way about presidential autocracy and
authoritarianism. And I genuinely wonder,
does Trump have something on Lindsey Graham?
And I know every time we talk about Lindsey,
someone will write to me, they'll say, David,
Lindsay Graham has to do what Trump wants.
Because if he doesn't, Trump will reveal that
Lindsey Graham is gay. I don't know if that's
true. It's been a rumor in DC DC for decades.
It's not unique to Trump that that could be
something he's holding over Lindsey Graham's
head. I just don't see that. I think that
there has to be something else that explains
to us why Lindsey Graham has become totally
subservient to Trump. Is that some implicit
or intimated promise about Lindsey's a role
in a second Trump term? Maybe? I don't know,
but he has to go. He's up for reelection in
2020 by the way, but it's a very safe seat
currently and he's probably going to get reelected.